what's up everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio presented by Saratoga
Springwater for another Sundance 2023
interview of the team behind Theater
Camp congratulations on your movie guys
I have not seen it I can't wait to hear
more about it I have seen the short
though so I feel like I've got a good
sense of what I'm in for with this for
anyone who is credited as a writer on
this I'm going to throw this to one of
you but most of our audience will not
know what your movie is just yet so can
you give a brief synopsis of Theater
Camp
sure uh yeah uh Theater Camp is about a
rundown Upstate New York Theater Camp
that uh kind of falls into disarray when
their beloved founder falls into a coma
and the Reigns of the Camp Fall to her
uh bro Sun uh Troy
um and he has to sort of uh find his way
in this very theatrical and intense
Community but it's also just a portrait
of the camp and and what it means to
like have a place where out casts can
kind of come together through their
shared passion okay so feature
directorial debut here it's not easy to
get your first feature off the ground so
can you guys maybe pinpoint a
misconception about what it takes to
make a first feature as a director
happened but then also what is a piece
of advice that you got that actually was
useful you used it and it was key to
getting this film off the ground
yeah I mean I think a big kind of
thing that we took a piece of advice
that was given to us and that kept
happening was that mistakes are going to
happen all the time everything's going
to fall apart you're going to lose your
financing and you're just going to have
to reinvent reinvent reinvent and every
obstacle is an opportunity for a new
idea and
um a movie is made up of your
compromises and your mistakes and they
end up being beautiful and to not freak
out about those things and I feel like
once we got Zen with that like we really
found our groove sounds like life
lessons yeah definitely I need to like
clip that out and just keep it in my
back pocket Molly for you do you
remember a specific time that you know a
specific film or experience you had that
first sparked the itch to direct maybe
something that actually made you feel
like you know what like I could do that
too
um
when I when my parents introduced me to
Robert Altman and John cassavedi's
movies I was just so
um floored with the freedom that he
allowed his they both allowed their
actors to have and I was like oh my God
I wanna
create a space where people can play in
that way
um and Nora Ephron so many people
um but you know it was it also
I got the itch from just being friends
with all these amazing people and being
an actor and working off of wonderful
other actors and wanting to like give
them opportunities where they could like
actually get to own their roles because
as an actor you don't always have much
control and so I really wanted to have
this sandbox where they could come and
uh kind of do what they want a little
bit
um with clear boundaries too I'll open
this up to the whole group here because
you've all worked on a lot of sets had a
lot of experiences with that idea in
mind can you pinpoint a time on this set
when you had the freedom to do something
with your character the production
overall that even with all your
experience you've never had before
Molly and I um we get to do a lot of our
stuff together in the film and we we
spend a lot of um time the four of us
writing um a very detailed scriptment
for the movie and it was very you know
uh largely written but a lot of room for
improvisation and we had
um a moment where there was a schedule
change and a whole snafu and somebody
wasn't available in their hours with
children so certain children weren't
available and basically we ended up with
this lot of time to utilize that we
didn't know we were going to have and so
Molly and I got to jump in and improvise
the scene part of which has ended up in
the film where we're working on a
writing of a musical together that that
gets written by our characters in the
movie and um it was very frightening to
kind of jump in because one of the first
things that Molly and I got to do
together but it um I think really set
the tone for the the set just feeling
like a space where there's no wrong
answers and that we were going to use
every moment we could and really lean
into the flexibility as a strength um
and I think that it's one of my favorite
moments
can anyone think about a time on set
going back to what you were just saying
about being able to kind of roll with
the punches here A Time on set when you
were all standing there and you're like
I don't know how this is going to work
we're not going to make our day or
something of the sorts and you guys
found a creative way to Pivot found some
unexpected magic in the scene is better
off for it I'd say those every day every
moment
but it was it was like every single day
was another problem to creatively solve
you know and I think it was nice that it
felt like such a collaboration it felt
like all hands on deck and what a group
of like Brilliant Minds to be those
hands you know
no I'll throw this one to you because
you also worked on the the short film
when you all first came up with the idea
to turn that into a feature what would
you say is the biggest difference
between how you envision the feature
then and what you guys wound up with
um
I mean
just you know purely like content wise
if you look at like our first draft
there are probably like seven additional
characters that were there that got cut
um we had like a whole other framing
device for the film for sort of like
window in
um
but that's sort of the beauty of it you
know it was like this five-year process
of us as a foursome just going over to
Ben's house and eating salad and and
only salad only salad
um but just like really trying to find
it together and I think we managed to
put something together that we all feel
really proud of yeah
it's so exciting I love hearing that I
love hearing about when when teams stick
together because I feel I feel like it's
a very special thing in this business
when you find the right collaborators
that you can trust and feel the need to
continue on with a lot of you have that
but then there's a bunch of newcomers to
this scenario here so Patty oh and Jimmy
I'll throw this one to you I think I
specifically read in the Press notes and
I love reading things like this that
everyone who worked on the short has a
shared creative language and trust and
you've had that since some of you were
13 years old which is pretty incredible
but for the three of you being newer and
stepping into that world is that
intimidating and is there anything about
that history between the collaborators
that you're working with that you found
enhance your own experience
I yeah it there uh just the lack of kind
of knowing
in in anything what what it's gonna be
what the experience is going to be like
but there was this like strange calm I
feel like I was lucky enough to know
it's like one of the only things I've
worked on where I was lucky enough to
know like everyone who is kind of
steering and in like such a positive way
that they're all so funny and nice and
it just like there was a comfort in
knowing that they were so excited about
how
um how fun it was going to be their
enthusiasm behind it was like very
reassuring so even though I kind of
because there was like The Improv
element of it
um that left a lot of questions going
into it you did feel like I don't know I
can I can only speak for myself
but I I had like I was like there's no
way it's barely it's not gonna be like
fun and
um I am cut from the film
but I have an amazing publicist so I'm
here at the table
um I've known Molly since I was two
so and she's been a sister to me ever
since and so just becoming a part of her
world with her best friends and
integrating into her life and all of
them then becoming my best friends has
just been like a magical experience and
so yes like The Improv was scary it was
like what's up what am I gonna say I
actually don't know
um but it was amazing it was such a
collaborative experience and these
people are so funny so it was it was
magical it was great I've known Molly
since I was 30. yeah so that's 20 years
I was just gonna say I think the uh just
like the collaborative nature of the
project was just very contagious and
being the new guy like I didn't know any
of them before this
um but stepping into what was clearly a
group of very close friends making
something together you never really know
how that's gonna go
um and as someone who you know makes my
own stuff and like works with friends it
just made me so happy like just
genuinely so happy for them to just
watch everything work and come together
and they made such a great team and like
I didn't even like I'm like a weekend I
barely I barely knew them like before
this and it I just was like proud like I
just felt proud of him I was like I'm
just so happy for you guys to like be
able to make such a cool thing with your
best friends and just be a part of it I
just was it was awesome Molly I'll throw
this one to you it's it's really special
and unusual to be able to make a
connection at such a young age with so
many people and to actually maintain
like what what's the secret sauce like I
don't know what the starting point is
but there's there's so many people out
there who who go to film school who go
to Theater Camp and you know you do
those programs and then you say goodbye
to those people and there's no guarantee
that you'll see even a single one of
them later on in life but I don't know
you guys seem to have stuck together and
that's that's pretty incredible yeah
I've paid all of them to still be my
friends
um
paid and salad if I was paid in salad
which I only eat
um no I uh I don't I don't know what it
is I think it's them being very special
and um you know like even I met Patty a
couple years ago and I was like oh my
God like we're made of the same kind
like I felt so it was I don't know I
just feel like I keep getting led to the
right people and collecting them along
the way and um and I I don't I don't
know what it is but what I'm excited
about with this movie is that it feels
like it's all of our shared humor and
we all just did what what like when Noah
makes me laugh that's just in the movie
and so it's fun to have this like piece
that's like oh this is that humor I
think everybody's humor is in this movie
and it's like a combination of that oh
my many follow-ups I want to go back to
the The Improv first because I know for
some jumping into a film that has a
significant amount of that can be very
intimidating so what is I don't know one
tip or trick or tool you would give to
another actor out there who is
intimidated to try improv for the first
time
I would say say the most inappropriate
horrible thing you can first and then
let the directors be like that was crazy
let's dial it back
um that's how I started yeah just go as
hard as you can right out of the gate
um I think improv is a good tool like a
good muscle to work even if you don't
feel good at it I think it's a good if
you're acting it's a good like
thing to pursue for at least a little
bit until you're you humiliate yourself
and then you should quit and then go
into underwater Welding which is what
I'm doing right now
I think it's helpful like
you know after you do a couple takes of
something you can kind of start to feel
the moments where you want to go off a
little bit and you want to explore those
moments and I think at like I don't know
I think I like doing a couple takes
first where you're just kind of getting
into the right flow and then
um and then you just get to really
explore those moments that you just you
could both feel were wanted to happen
and then just just kind of let them
I I think as as writers that the four of
us you know I we've uh experienced
improv from both directions and I think
we really wanted to create a situation
where uh no matter where you were coming
into the project from in terms of your
own comfortability or experience with
improv you felt protected and like you
were in the right
um space to to really go for it and so I
think we tried in terms of the structure
of how we would write things to always
have a very clear place to begin and if
it was a particularly story heavy moment
or sequence we're seeing even have a
written scene to begin with and just
always have a landing pad so that you
know which which on occasion would make
it into the film but often was just a
beautiful takeoff point so that people
felt like the pressure wasn't on coming
in with all of this content ready it was
just
um knowing exactly what your parameters
are and and feeling even in the midst of
free flying which is what improv is that
you're not entirely without a parachute
of some kind yeah it was it was great I
will say because I was so nervous about
not like where where to take the the
character and like what information I
can add and I like because you don't
know what like other improvi what other
actors are going to improvise like later
on in the movie or whatever but it was
so guided I think Nick and Molly were
like like you were saying or I I think
it was in this interview but it was like
they were so present and being like more
of that like if you were kind of hitting
something that was you like knew
instantly if you were doing something
right which felt really great you can't
remember which interview you said
something in that's when you're doing
Sundance right because that's me that
means you're getting the widest possible
platform for your movie you can't see if
there's a big hole in the back of my
head my brain is just dripping it up I
have that same hole in the back of my
brain
um I wanted to go back to what you were
saying about the idea of this movie
being filled with things that like you
all find funny and I I guess I'll throw
this this to you what what is it like
working with material like that but
knowing that it's accessible to the
widest possible audience and it's it's
not just funny to you but it'll be you
know it'll be funny and maybe
thematically relevant to the widest
possible viewership yeah well I think
that that Keys into the sort of you know
like because we knew we were making
improvised movie we definitely wanted to
have the discipline of having a really
clear structure having a really clear
set of like being on the rails you know
like we wanted characters that were not
just from this world of theater and so I
think the idea of of just trying to tell
like
an authentically heartfelt story in that
in that world is makes it more Universal
even if we are throwing in a couple of
cheetah Rivera references and you know
um and so I I yeah well I was gonna say
I think Ben got this advice that like
sometimes the most Niche specific things
can be the most universal yes exactly
yeah and I think this is particular to
this movie that we're writing you know
what's at the very core of our passion
like we in terms of like write what you
know we kind of really took that to
heart
um and it's what brought us together in
the first place um the four of us in
different ways Molly and I started doing
theater together we were children and
Nick and I in high school and with Molly
and and Noah and our you know late teens
and early 20s and so I think the fact
that I think that that's really palpable
that shared passion so even if it's not
necessarily circumstantially you're not
a theater person per se I feel like you
can feel the the love that we have for
that and I think that anybody can can
connect that to whatever it is that
centers them and their community and
hopefully that's what makes it a very
accessible kind of heartfelt story so in
in the short I know you guys poke fun at
certain like Theater Camp and Industry
cliches I'm assuming the same thing is
true the features so what's an example
of something you all experienced in this
industry or in theater camper wherever
else you studied that you were
especially excited to like skewer in
this movie and maybe it was cathartic
for you
I mean I definitely think the way in
which theater teachers will introduce
material that is like far too mature for
the children that they are educating is
like so like funny especially with the
the like earnestness with which they do
that yeah I think just generally
watching people who take themselves a
little too seriously is funny you know
um and I think the theater the universe
of theater is filled with people who
take themselves very very seriously
um and it's something we wanted to like
honor but also make fun of a little bit
you know I don't think this movie would
would have worked if it wasn't made by
four people that genuinely like love and
come from theater like you can't really
make fun of something
without it coming off as mean unless
deep down you truly love it and I think
that really comes across
I'm faithful Jimmy I feel like what I'll
say is my character I think is more is
like a on the business side villainesque
villain e
um and I feel like I was really excited
to get to play someone who in terms of
like the business side of the
entertainment industry seeing a lot of
people who have completely dead-eyed
faces it will say the the worst thing
you'll ever hear to your face with like
a and like the in like the most like
syrupy tone just getting to just getting
to play with that playing with my dead
eyes my Dead face empty heart can't lose
but
but like there's so many like 75 moments
of Patty doing that that aren't in the
movie so many moments of us uh that
aren't in the movie because she's not in
the movie she was cut from the movie no
but uh so many moments of us making fun
of other theater stuff like we could
have like a mini series of us just
poking fun of Industry stuff that are
like because we just have so much
footage uh but maybe like shouldn't be
released because then maybe we wouldn't
get to work again but but uh yeah well
maybe we'll release that speaker series
into existence best things here yeah all
right I have to let you guys go soon
you're getting my favorite game and you
guys are the only ones who are getting
this because it's an ensemble you
clearly know each other very well
my favorite sub-genre is the slasher
movie sub genre okay I am gonna put you
all in a slasher movie right now and I
have cliches from those movies and I
want you to tell me which person like
real person not their character best
suits the description I'm about to give
you in one that's fun and I'm just gonna
make the role first person to shout out
and answer says the right answer so good
luck to you all who is most likely to
not realize that they're in a horror
movie and to go and investigate a
strange noise and be the first one to
die Owen
[Laughter]
why
thank you this is sort of a childlike
wonder about it and I think if you were
doing strange noise he'd be like let's
call you guys it could be a fun
adventure exactly exactly I would call
all of you and be like I'm here I just
got killed
I feel like that turned into a
compliment I like that who is the most
likely to sacrifice themselves for the
others
maybe Nikki I would say Nick or Jimmy
very sweet I'll say Nick
I'll say Jimmy here's a less flattering
one who is the most likely to trip and
fall while running from the killer Molly
Molly there's no denial there so I'm
assuming yeah
who is the most likely to be the first
one to figure out who the Killer is Ben
or Nick Ben I could see Ben piecing it
together very fast yes I feel like Ben
Ben would have a good like realization
face like the like
purely for the coverage it's me
this is my favorite one who is the most
likely to realize there's a slasher and
just saying you know what this too
scary I'm leaving
I'm brave no but I think Patty would say
that like to the murderer's face yeah
it would be like I just ordered an Uber
traditionally I've been working on
therapy on my codependence on my
conflict aversion so I feel more
assertive than ever in 2023 so I think I
would have the tools communication tools
to activate that conversation with an
abuser and a killer is an abuser let's
just look at it now
justification right there all right I'm
gonna give you two more who's the most
likely to be the last one standing
but Jimmy you'd be the person that like
they think that has a death scene in the
beginning but that comes back at the end
it's like in the truck and you're like
all bloody but do you know what my last
question is who is most likely to be the
person that you thought died but comes
back at the last
time
we have a winner I have to let you go
you guys have a lot of promoting to do
huge congratulations on Theater Camp it
is hands down one of the movies I'm most
excited to see at this Festival thank
you enjoy your time here to everybody
out there keep an eye out for Theater
Camp and we'll see you soon with more
Sundance 2023 interviews